frau wagenknecht wenn die impfpflicht
kommt halten sie sich daran lassen sie
sich impfen oder eine impfpflicht
ich wusste zunächst mal richtig stellen
ich bin nicht prinzipiell eine impf
skeptikerin also ich bin eigentlich ein
großer freund des impfens also ich habe
alle regulären impfungen die man so
haben kann bekommen und ich wäre auch
einmal durchaus überzeugt dass eine
impfpflicht sinn hätte wenn wir in einer
situation werden dass wir impfstoffe
hätten wo klar ist man lässt sich einmal
oder zweimal impfen und dann ist man
sozusagen immun und außerdem würde auch
die impfung die übertragung des virus
verhindern
dann wäre zumindest bei den
bevölkerungsgruppen die wir auf jeden
fall schützen wollen und die mit ihnen
zu tun haben wäre das ein
erwähnenswerter gedanken nur das ist
hier nicht die situation wir haben ein
virus das ständig mutiert wir haben
impfstoffe die zwar die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines schweren
verlaufs verringern das ist so also das
glaube ich sollte man nicht bestreiten
das ist deshalb auch durchaus ratsam vor
allem für ältere menschen dass sie sich
impfen lassen da bin ich auch völlig
überzeugt aber es sind impfstoffe die
ihren schutz nach einer gewissen zeit
verlieren und die außerdem natürlich
auch relativ neuartig sind und deswegen
finde ich muss jeder doch selber die die
abwägung treffen wie ist mein risiko bei
corona wir sehen auch bei den
intensivstationen mehr als zwei drittel
waren immer über 60 jahre alt die in den
intensivstationen liegen das mittlere
sterbealter ist 83 jahre bis heute das
hat sich verändert das heißt verwandt
sein der
impfpflicht ist ja sozusagen das ende
der diskussion da heißt es dann mehr
jetzt haben wir aus diskutiert jetzt
haben wir aus argumentiert jetzt kommt
die pflicht und jetzt bitteschön frau
wagenknecht jetzt müssen sie es machen
halten sie sich daran lassen sie sich
dann unter einer impfpflicht impfen
naja wir müssen ja erst einmal sehen wie
viele menschen nach dieser extremen
omikron welle die wir zurzeit bekommen
überhaupt noch nicht geimpft und nicht
genesen sind und das sind ja alles jetzt
auch neue entwicklungen die konnte man
so auch nicht vorhersehen omikron ist
zum glück nicht ganz so gefährlich wie
die vorangegangenen
varianten des virus ist es aber sehr
viel ansteckender die impfstoffe die wir
jetzt haben sind gar nicht für omicron
gemacht das heißt die frage ist doch
auch mit welchen impfstoff verpflichten
wir die menschen ich verstehe zwar
zeigen auf wie geschäftsführer man nur
die frage ist ja so einfach bei einer
impfpflicht ist die argumentation halt
zu ende wenn das gesetz kommt müssen sie
machen sie es dann auch
also meine hoffnung ist dass wir im
bundestag und sehr seriös und sehr auch
nicht nur emotional sondern rational mit
diesem thema beschäftigen eine
impfpflicht ist wirklich eine sehr hohe
hürde es gibt das bisher bisher
eigentlich nur bei der masernimpfung da
auch sozusagen nicht ganz generell
sondern wenn man eben in kitas ist oder
da auch arbeitet das hat eine logik weil
die masern impfung schützt davor andere
zu infizieren und es gibt kinder die man
nicht impfen kann dies nur noch über
wissen vergangenheit als sie liebevoll
dass das tut mir wirklich leid wir
diskutieren das alles und das sind ganz
wichtige argumente nur ein wichtiges
argument ist ja auch ob das dann die
menschen tatsächlich überhaupt zum
impfen bringt wenn die impfpflicht kommt
deswegen ich finde das eine ganz
entscheidende frage lasse sie sich
impfen wenn die impfpflicht kommt oder
sagen sie mache ich dann trotzdem nicht
also ich finde so abstrakt kann man das
nicht beantworten es gibt ja auch
forschungen an anderen impfstoffen
vielleicht bekommen wir einen super
überzeugenden tollen impfstoff der dann
wirklich wirkt wo man weiß für alle
künftigen mutanten also auch an sowas
regieren aber sich an gesetze der
wirksam ist noch deutlich an gesetze zu
halten das ist ja das was herr stegner
gerade beschrieben das ist eine ganz
einfache wir wissen noch gar nicht was
für ein
wir wissen noch gar nicht was für ein
gesetz geben wird und ob es überhaupt
eins gibt und was das bedeutet bedeutet
dass ich muss mich alle halbe jahre
impfen lassen bedeutet dass mit welchen
impfstoff muss ich mich impfen lassen
und meine sachen es ist das kein
sinnvoller weg und ich glaube wir haben
den leuten auch tatsächlich etwas oder
diejenigen die das gesagt haben die den
den druck erweckt haben die impfpflicht
ist das ultimative ende der pandemie
haben den leuten etwas vorgemacht oder
sie haben sich geirrt dass man ja auch
sein am anfang haben wir gehofft es gibt
eine herdenimmunität wir sehen jetzt es
gibt länder mit wo die verwachsenen fast
zu 95 97 prozent durch geimpft sind die
inzidenz dort sind teilweise bei über
2000 also es ist ja nicht so dass die
impfung die pandemie beendet was die
pandemie beenden kann und das ist meine
hoffnung aktuell wissen kann man das
nicht ist tatsächlich wenn ein großteil
der bevölkerung entweder über eine
impfung oder auch über die infektion die
bei omikron eben scheinbar doch weniger
gefährlich ist oder hoffen sie weniger
gefährlich ist wenn ein großteil der
bevölkerung immunisiert ist dann sind
wir hoffentlich heraus und natürlich
wünschen uns alle thomas und die wackelt
ja gewalt also ihre zweifel daran ob das
gesetz wirklich kommt die sind ja völlig
berechtigt aber das möchte ich auch
einmal festhalten wenn die impfpflicht
dann kommt dann wissen sie noch nicht
genau ob sie sich an dieses gesetz
anhalten werden
das hängt auch davon ab welche
impfstoffe zur verfügung stehen und ob
ich die überzeugend finde das ist ja
sicher für viele auch eine frage also
ich habe zum beispiel immer gesagt wenn
es einen klassischen traditionellen
impfstoff gibt der allerdings auch
wirkungsvoll sein muss dann wäre ich
durchaus bereit wie gesagt ich werde
natürlich auch gegen andere dinge impfen
sehr gerne sogar ich bin froh wenn man
sich durch impfungen verlässlich vor
krankheiten schützen kann aber es muss
eben verlässlich sein und was ich nicht
machen würde wäre jetzt irgendwie im
halbjahresrhythmus eine im verstehen
eben aber tatsächlich das verfahren neu
ist und niemand mehr sagen kann wie
lange funktioniert das und hat das
vielleicht dann stoffe folgen für das
gesamte immunsystem die man derzeit
nicht kennt